I'm at an age where all of my friends are settling down
and getting married and having kids
and every time I hear the news:
"I'm getting married!"
Though I say:
"Congratulations!"
All I can think is:
What's wrong with me?
Why isn't anyone proposing to me?
I've never been proposed to before.
What if I die alone?
What if no one ever wants me in the end?
Maybe I should be a feminist
and propose to my boyfriend.
No, that's weird.
I'm self-aware enough to know that this like
pressure to feel like I want to get married
comes from like Fairy Tale books and Disney movies
and reading the vampire trilogies when
I was 13 years old.
But even though you know all of that
you can't help but feel like:
I want to get married.
But I'm also self-aware enough to know that
I don't want to get married because I want to
declare my eternal love for someone.
No, I just want to get married because I want the party.
I want a giant cake, and an expensive dress
and a whole day where it's all about me.
It's like your birthday but bigger!
One day, you're going to get married
and that means you get to get
a really expensive, nice dress
and all of your friends have to come
and be nice to you, and give you gifts,
and then you have a big feast and you share this day
with somebody, but that person doesn't matter
as much as you because this is your day.
And it's kind of weird because when you about
actual marriage.
That going you're going to settle down with someone
and spend your entire life with them.
It seems really dumb to get married after
only knowing someone for a couple of years.
Right?  You should spend a lot of time
with that person so you know that you can tolerate
each other.
I want to kill you, but I wont.
It's what love is, baby.
And yet we put so much pressure on getting married.
You know?
Like even as we get older, if we're not
married we kind of think that person is like weird
or not worthy of love.
And like I haven't fully decided like
whether or not I want to get married.
Because you know there's that whole debate
of like whether or not monogamy is even feasible
in today's world where we're going to live till 120
and people change all the time
and we're getting more open to different views.
I haven't really like nailed down my
thoughts on marriage.  Much less kids--
That's like a whole other video I don't even want to
get into right now.
But I just kind of wanted to talk about it
and see what people thought like:
If you got married really young, did you get divorced?
Do you agree with marriage?
Is that what you're looking for?
Are you like me?  And you just really want to
get married because the idea of it is really cool.
And you get to have a really dope party
where everyone just gets fucked up
in your name.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Although now I'm in Ant Man so I should
probably be more supportive of the Marvel Universe.
So, stay...
Marvelous!
I'm Anna Man.
I'm Anna Man.  Stay Marvelous.
I'm getting married!
*gasps*  Congratulations!
I know!  You will never believe how he proposed
So we went to the Taj Mahal.  And it was just amazing.
And I'm so excited for the wedding.
I'm going to have pigs in a blanket and
I'm thinking about maybe we're going to have
3 kids.  We're going to have 2 girls
and then a hermaphrodite.  It's going to be so great!
And their names are going to be Billy, Jilly , and Lilly!